Democratic senator Bernie Sanders who
you probably know is also running for
president in 2020 is now calling for the
House of Representatives to immediately
start an impeachment inquiry into Donald
Trump and despite the fact that what he
wants is an impeachment inquiry there
have been a ton of posts and discussions
and comments online which initially said
bernie is calling for Trump's removal
and that's just not what Bernie did
Bernie is calling for the removal of
Trump by voting him out in 2020 that's
one way that Bernie Sanders is saying
Donald Trump should be removed but
Bernie Sanders has only called for the
beginning of an impeachment inquiry
that's step one in the impeachment
process interestingly this happened at a
campaign rally late last week it was not
mentioned for days by media outlets and
when it was initially mentioned a lot of
the reaction to the story was completely
misunderstanding what it is that Bernie
Sanders said so this is the right call
that Bernie Sanders is making and Bernie
Sanders like the David Pakman show
like other shows we all realized that
the Republican Senate is not going to
convict Donald Trump and actually remove
him from office but the facts support
starting an impeachment inquiry period
and that's why I'm glad Bernie's doing
this he said at this rally in Henderson
Nevada quote I believe the House
Judiciary Committee should begin
impeachment inquiries that is inquiries
not impeachment to determine whether or
not
Trump has committed impeachable offenses
this is an important change not because
Bernie saying it will make impeachment
more of a reality more quickly but
because it's starting to become a
distraction does Bernie not think there
should be an impeachment inquiry
what's wrong with Bernie why isn't
Bernie willing to say it well now Bernie
Sanders has made it clear that he
supports an impeachment inquiry but I've
got to make this same statement again
that I've been saying for a while an
impeachment inquiry is not impeachment
and impeachment is not removal okay
the process is inquiry during which
there is testimony investigation debate
by the house if they determine that
impeachment articles should be filed
though
articles are then filed by the house
they require a majority simple majority
50% plus one of the 435 House members
then there is a trial of sorts that the
house puts forward all of the evidence
they believe supports the impeachment of
the president at which point the Senate
votes on whether to convict and remove
the president or not and to convict you
need 2/3 of the Senate all we're talking
about here all that Bernie Sanders is
talking about is an impeachment inquiry
so there are a whole bunch of wrong
reactions to this news the first wrong
reaction to this news is that many have
said Oh
Bernie's calling for the removal of
Trump but that's not what he's doing
it's just not it's wrong in two ways
number one
Bernie's just calling for the inquiry
which happens before impeachment
articles are even filed and number two
even impeachment by the house wouldn't
remove Trump only a conviction by the
Senate would remove Trump and it's not
gonna happen
okay that's not the point the point is
we want to expose what Trump has done
and potentially weaken him in 2020 there
are others who are reacting to this
saying Bernie so weak he's riding the
fence
he's only calling for an inquiry he
should just buckle down and call for
impeachment it's a silly criticism
Bernie's a senator Bernie would
conceivably be one of the people voting
on the trial that would be brought forth
by these articles of impeachment if they
were ever filed it would be in a sense
inappropriate for Bernie to say now we
must remove Trump what most senators
have been saying is that they believe
either an inquiry should start or that
the house should file articles and then
later the Senate would ultimately be
making the decision about how do they
want to vote and do they get that
two-thirds support so Bernie's one
hundred percent correct here he's saying
do the inquiry that's the required first
step it's great news maybe it'll put
more pressure on people like Nancy
Pelosi who have been sort of hesitant to
consider impeachment and Bernie Sanders
is you know some people will criticize
him for this but I believe that the the
net positive benefit of him just saying
this and getting it out of the way makes
sense I'm glad he did it I agree let's
start that inquiry as soon as humanly
possible